hey hey am i interrupting something
important impossible i work for the
government i've been quite open about
this around the office i don't want this
parks department to build any parks
because i don't believe in government i
think that all government
is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream is to have the park system
privatized and run entirely for profit
by corporations
like chuck e cheese
they have an impeccable business model i
would rather work for chuck e cheese
well i will definitely think about it
i like the sound of that definitely i'm
gonna leave before you change your mind
mr swanson i presume lot 48 thoughts yes
no me park giving the park to me still
mulling she's insatiable she's like a
little dog with a chew toy all right you
guys all right all right i'll ask him
everybody wants to know what your
decision is someone on the phone about
the park you know i don't think i even
want it
oh man
the clavicle's still really hurting me
ron swanson it is my pleasure to inform
you that you are a finalist for the job
of assistant city manager chris i feel i
should remind you that i do not believe
that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me i will walk
deeper into the belly of the beast if it
means i'm able to further limit reckless
government spending i mean i have so
many ideas
some are simple like take down traffic
lights and eliminate the post office the
bigger ones will be tougher like
bring all of this crumbling to the
ground every time someone calls and
requests a meeting with you i always
schedule it for march 31st
why because i didn't think march 31st
existed
30 days has september april march and
november june and november
today is march 31st i know
so then how many meetings do i have
today
93.
okay
okay well
you know what to do
right
to me
this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape so your department
banned me from attending games just
because i yell you suck at the players
according to the complaint you yelled it
at five-year-old girls who suck
why is that so hard to understand
i ask you is this too revealing for a
public pool kindly get your groin off my
desk
so my body makes you uncomfortable too
how we doing
pretty good i may have promised a new
aquatic center to somebody is that a
problem i diagnosed two melanomas
they're both benign
how many more meetings 20.
april was supposed to be the moat that
kept the citizen barbarians away from
swanson castle instead she blew up the
castle and stabbed me in the face i
hired you to do one thing
just one
i don't care that you text all day and
sleep at your desk in fact i encourage
it but only because you were doing that
one thing
keeping this crap
off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
ron you have to help me chris is making
me do some stupid management training
leadership course now that you run the
animal control department you have
qualified for the chris trager
management training seminar or ketumps
yeah it's not a great acronym but it is
a great seminar
can you get me out of it
yes
normally if given a choice between doing
something and nothing i choose to do
nothing but i will do something if it
helps someone else do nothing i'd work
all night if it meant nothing got done
ron swanson and april that gate
literally my two favorite people in the
catalogued universe april will not be
participating in your pointless course
because she has more important things to
do like
not participating in your pointless
course i just want april to become as
great a department head as yourself
which is why this is pointless i've been
head of the parks department for 12
years and i never had any management
training course ron you've never been
katums
i'm legally required to get tumps every
department head otherwise we are open to
all kinds of liability what are you
saying i'm saying that tomorrow during
the seminar april is going to have a
classmate and spoiler alert it's alf
it's you
this went poorly
my idea of a perfect government is
one guy who sits in a small room at a
desk and the only thing he's allowed to
decide is who to nuke
the man is chosen based on some kind of
iq test
and maybe also a physical tournament
like a decathlon
and women
are brought to him maybe
when he desires them
can i help you
hi my class is here on a field trip and
i'm supposed to interview someone for a
school project okay
you can wait at that table and someone
will be here sometime
but aren't you here now
no
my report's due tomorrow what's it on
why government matters
really
it's never too early to learn that the
government is a greedy piglet that
suckles on a taxpayer's teat until they
have sore chapped nipples
i'm gonna need a different metaphor to
give this nine-year-old
what's your name ma'am
lauren burkis lauren
my name is ron swanson and i'm gonna
tell you everything you need to know
about the miserable screwed up world of
local government
you mustered in your mustache
don't sass me berkus
let's get started this is your lunch
now you should be able to do whatever
you want to with this right if you want
to eat all of it great if you want to
throw it away in the garbage that's your
prerogative but here i come
the government
and i get to take 40
of your lunch
and that lauren is how taxes work
but that's not fair you're learning
uh-oh
capital gains tax
and that lauren is how fdr ruined this
country lauren going now ready to head
back well i guess it's time for you to
head home
i've really enjoyed talking with you
you are and this is not a joke
much smarter than most of the people who
work in this building i like talking
with you too mr swanson
ron
hang on hang on i have something for you
this
is a claymore landmine
use that to protect your property
thanks ron
you got it
i feel that some structural changes
could really unlock this department's
potential jerry hmm i believe you were
capable of much more
i'm not nonsense look in the mirror huh
you are an intelligent charismatic
beautiful superhero i'm making you head
of public relations which means you'll
be leading the daily briefing sessions
excellent idea this is my favorite part
about having a new city manager they
always try to shake things up and their
ideas are terrible and it brings city
hall to a grinding halt
i just grab a few donuts sit back and
enjoy the show i got a second box of
donuts if anybody
what the is this
this mr director is your new desk
okay this desk is the epitome of the
swedish concept of yamsteldakt or
equality imagine someone needs your
attention somebody say my name chris
swivel
what is jerry you told me to say your
name and you did a great job superstar
someone else say something you look like
a freak swivel
april that is not a very good attitude i
will keep my eye on you
from my circular desk where i can see
everything tiny swivel
see how it works
what about my office and its many walls
that becomes a new public waiting room
and we got rid of that giant pillar that
was in front of your door
i loved that pillar it made it really
annoying to stand in my doorway
well get over it because it's gone
you're gonna be more accessible than
ever
april do you have that usage report that
i asked for
[Music]
anything for you jerry thank you
oh come on
why
excuse me
there's a sign at ramps at park that
says do not drink the sprinkler water so
i made sun tea with it and now i have an
infection
sir
sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir
sir are you aware
that there is
waste in your water system
you